so from whom did yoga originate Lord
Shiva among the great deities of
Hinduism most personifies a practice of
yoga you will see the picture of him
from a temp in at a temple where he
seated under tree of knowledge and sha
is a god of knowledge and so he's
crushing the male child ringer Bel male
child and as you can see there's always
a serpent with him and uh then is always
a
trident a pitchfork a trident you can
say and then his feet as you can see are
Bine feet
Bine like b or something yeah and the
devotees have to face a sides of the
north I will send the sides of the north
above the clouds be like the most high
so when a person is practicing yoga they
are linking their mind with shiva's mind